un gioco che dà una carica così in
questa colonna sonora che cosa vi
aspettate scontri battaglie epiche
incredibili e invece maghetto
ma quello già un gomito slogati ssimo
bella a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo io sono fa vj oggi siamo su
non mi ricordo come si chiama sto gioco
anche perché non c'è il titolo nel menu
c'è una missione 1 bene tu hai un'armata
di persone di legno tanto stanno da
bando questi che sta facendo io posso
schierare le mie truppe così no su
piazzarle e andare incontro sti
cerebrolesi anche i cannoni a caso vai
vai così voglio vedere cosa succede
spero che sia casa non fa niente lie
flat la madonna carica non è fortissimo
sparate miei prodi sparate aia siamo
rimasti soltanto in due ma solo uno e
vabbè adesso non farmi fuori cannoni
però non è facile ragazzi c'è un
problema di fondo qua ne è rimasto un
cannone ma è pure storto suo cannone ma
che schifo schierato male ma era solo
per vedere come funziona ma perché possa
al novecento scemo per farvi vedere cosa
fa questo per curiosità veniamo
strapazzi va bene ok canoni qua da
lontano da lontano che prende tutto
dai che dite vediamo vediamo cosa
succede un cannone prende la distanza no
spero perfetto bravissimo guarda che
allora quanto forte è un pesce ma uno
dei miei soldati sono fatti di carta
pesta rega ma fanno veramente vomitare
le mie truppe ma non vale così
addirittura le difese ma siamo scemi
va bene perfetto gli ho già smi inviati
tutti ho vinto a questi li mettiamo cui
anno a questo cos'è cecchino cyber di
sniper li mettiamo qua 2 sniper
perfetto e poi mettiamo tutti questi
così un cannone lo vorrei se posso non
ci inglobano tantissimo proviamoci lo
stesso è poi questo sta qua vai bene non
stai perché ci ha dato a pure
l'altro che palle sono nato il secondo
fanta le mie strà meno male che non ho
fatto io la guerra sonora un casino per
l'attenzione primo gruppo andato
incredibile storica sta cosa
il primo gruppo all'altro michael ii dai
due in due un cecchino solo il cecchino
non ti hanno cagato spara bravo la
guerra da solo bravissimo spara tutti si
fa ammazza lì ma non al muro ai a loro
un deficiente questa faccenda sala ma se
tutti la bandiera hai vinto ma se lo
vedi già sta cosa nella sapevo porca
vacca morta
va bene facciamo che andiamo al menu
principale facciamo altre cose missioni
a questa a ondate va bene ok vediamo
cosa riusciamo a fare che sicuramente
andrà benissimo poi proviamo sbarra
bravi c'è chi guarda i cecchini quanto
forti sparate sparate idioti spara bravi
dai che vi salta le truppe bravissimi a
cervello next già le ondate riesco a
farle meglio perché mi chiamavi prima
era inguardabile questo cos'è il
granatiere attenzione
vediamo come team ha lanciate le grate
non state fermi mancia telegramma o mica
fermo sta deficiente bravo così ti
voglio con altre grandate voi dovevate
il bordello
in granata proprio sotto il cannone
attenzione boom perfetto toccarono
lescot beach cosa vedo se va beh no
vabbè ma siete scemi già che io le ho
messe le coperture per difendervi
dovreste difendervi però vabbè non fa
niente
sparate sparate sparate bravi quanto è
avvincente questo combattimento
ho la pelle d'oca ma fanno danno se armi
o sparano per hobby è che più storto lui
che non so chi no perfetto rubrica
crosta cannone next ma dài dài sparate
porca vacca quelli devono correre fra
iran da voi sparate sparati tutti contro
uno tutti contro una sinistra focus su
uno solo focus su quello e non muore mai
però parate porca vacca non va giù non
va giù
non va giù ma neanche morto vai vai 22
forza forza dai l'edizione dai dai dai
raga dai rami deludente mandata ti prego
ti prego fallo fuori
minchia che annuncia ho mai avuto qui
stanza neanche la finale dei mondiali
del 2006 ciao costanzia ti prego sto al
minuto almeno tu è morto è morto non
stanno ammazzando malisz guardali
sparate porca o spa sparate causa
teleschermi spara eccolo camina sparate
li ucci letto fatelo fuori per l'amore
di gesù ti prego ti prego almeno tu ti
prego ti supplico c'è anche la difesa
cioè la difesa mai la dife madonna t a
chi ti do tutta la che vuoi nel
mondo nell'universo ti regalo tutta la
un ora prima cosa vedo sono tre
sniper quelli proviamo perfetto aveva
perso guarda che guarda che truppe
efficienti
guardali
ma la guerra è già finita da un pezzo
quando arrivò se vuoi che non è che
madonna ma guarda qual è la differenza
tra le mie truppe e le altre truppe
questo potrebbe essere praticamente un
bene dei delle sci ma neanche le scimmie
proprio le i germi in teoria quelli
partiamo che sono morti in tre
va bene di successo sono morti non sono
accaduti e vabbè ho vinto io sono forte
ecco perfetto mai perfetto
chissà che non vi beccate neanche tra
mille anni così e la guerra andavate
tensione sensore questa mi è piaciuta
sparate sbarrate bravi spara spara bravo
2 contro 2 dai nei miei sogni i miei i
miei hanno dei problemi
i miei hanno dei problemi non so se si è
capito due scarsi contro due forti 2
scarsi contro le parti mi continuano a
camminare sul legno ma guarda guarda
guarda loschi fonterra sparava donna che
nervi ma dai che quale ti ammazzerei te
lo giuro sparate porca vacca non per
finta o spostate almeno le difese di
spostate va bene
eccole sono sparite le difese era
difficile basta giocato un'ora sta roba
non l'aria però mai più indietro nella
mia vita quest ora però ho capito come
fare le guerre
spero che vi sia piaciuto ragazzi quasi
se vi piace secondo invece che veniva
fischiato non ci vediamo da ragazzi
[Musica]